this week we're seeing the culmination
of decades of hard work
important work
and principled work
after hours of oral arguments the
supreme court appears set to uphold a
mississippi law that bans abortions
after 15 weeks setting the stage to at
least
radically alter rose precedent and at
best yes
to overturn
roe v wade
the landmark decision that has led to
the abortion of at least 62 million
innocent american babies
since 1973
a generational genocide of america's
unborn
now worshipped by the left as a savior
for women for far too long roe v wade
seemed untouchable
just 10 years ago with obama in the
white house and his supreme court
stacked with pro-choice justices this
day it felt
very far off
until now
because of the endless efforts of
pro-life groups activists educators
mothers
because of major technological
advancements
that prove that even at the earliest
stages of life
as king david wrote in psalm 193
for you created my inmost being
you knit me together in my mother's womb
i praise you because i am fearfully and
wonderfully made
your works are wonderful i know that
full well
your eyes saw my unformed body
unformed bodies
knit together by god
not the decision of planned parenthood
and as a calm culmination because of
donald trump
appointing three strong conservative
supreme court justices
it's all there
it had to happen to make this moment
possible
and sometimes it's worth taking stock
and being grateful
for the courage of so many
generations before us for so long that
made this special moment possible a
moment for life
and despite what the captured corporate
media tells you most americans are
actually against what roe v wade
protects
even if they don't necessarily realize
it
65 percent of americans according to a
gallup poll in 2018
say abortion in the second trimester
should be illegal
even though
roe v wade allows it
it's actually just a small
loud angry minority of radical feminists
who really support unfettered abortion
and now today this week
they are in full blown panic mode
they're terrified that the states that
we the people not nine people in black
robes will soon get a say determining
the all-important question of life which
really should be
only answered
by god
and in many states but unfortunately not
all the genus genocide of generations
could of the unborn come to the end
so in their desperation the far left is
trying to discredit
members of the conservative supreme
court
for simply being
men do any of you men
have any eggs or the possibility of
carrying a fetus how dare you talk about
what a fetus wants you have no idea um
when it comes to
this decision this issue men don't play
a factor men aren't being held
responsible
for having sex there's no man mentioned
to two men
clarence thomas and brett kavanaugh who
were credibly accused of violating the
sanctity of women
you know
both of them got away with it of course
and got on the court but having them
sort of stand up and sort of soberly
argue whether or not women are owned by
the state
it's it it made me feel some kind of way
and when it comes to the science far
left justice sonia sotomayor this
self-described wise latina
well she doesn't want to hear it
disgustingly comparing babies in the
womb
to dead people
in israel 40
of dead people
who if you touch their feet
the foot will recoil
there are spontaneous acts by dead brain
people
so i don't think
that a response
to
uh by a fetus necessarily proves
that there's a sensation of pain
or that there's consciousness
you know touching the the feet of dead
people that's the same as a fetus that's
science to the wise latina
meanwhile their leader the real speaker
of the house comrade cortes topped all
of this idiocy with a statement of her
own
saying on twitter quote
reminder that brett kavanaugh still
remains credibly accused of sexual
assault on multiple accounts with
corroborated details and this year the
fbi admitted it never fully investigated
yet the court is letting him decide and
whether to get this
legalized forced birth in the u.s
no recusal
yes she just uh referred to not aborting
a baby child birth as legalized
forced birth
that is who they are
they are extremists
and hopefully soon
they will lose
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else